I remember when I was young hearing
horse stories about a dentist who would
give kids a little pink pill that would
turn their entire mouth pink and
highlight all the spots that they missed
while brushing so I went on the internet
and I found them actually I found 250 of
them what better place to try one of
these then on YouTube where hundreds of
people can laugh at me and make fun of
me in the comments so I figured we
should give one of these ago right this
is the tablet this is my mouth and let's
do it taste of pink how long do I do
this for 30 seconds all right it's
purple now oh yeah
look at this [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] pro
dentists get at me so that's what it
would look like if you did a pretty good
job brushing and thank you thank you
thank you but there's got to be some
people around here who think they're
really good at brushing but are actually
pretty bad let's find some gross ass
teeth my usual dental routine i floss
and then I brush my teeth I brush my
teeth every night before I go to bed I
scrub really hard I'm like I go ham on
my teeth sometimes I just don't brush my
teeth at all cuz I'm just tired and lazy
then told this closing taps sounds like
something you put in your mouth after
you get herpes they show you where like
your teeth are dirty right this looks
like an ecstasy pill what are you guys
giving me all right let's do this
I'm terrified to do this so I push chew
it off first tastes like bubble gum
[Music]
ooh
I just spent purple stuff oh all right
moment of truth
okay see the preview so bad [ __ ] looks
kind of like I missed a lot on the
bottom side I got a little bit more in
the crevices on the bottom I don't see a
lot of bad thoughts I'll probably see
you like the top of my teeth looks like
it needs a little bit more cleaning mmm
SME my tongues dirty too
I'm really surprised it doesn't look
like I got everything and I'm just like
surprised that it's not everywhere I'm
here's a little helpful it makes me
think that like I'm doing things right
you know it doesn't look catastrophic if
there's one thing I'd like to say to my
dentist right now if I'm sorry I'll do
better don't tell my mom - my future
dentists I am really sorry
at least I give you a good business
there's videos definitely NS FD not safe
for dentists
[Laughter]
[Music]